since you've had also from another place
some debates that were inspired by the
assembly Theory paper let me ask you
about God is there any room
for Notions of God in assembly Theory um
God yeah I I don't know what God is a I
mean so God exists in our minds created
by
selection so human beings have created
the concept of God in the same way that
human beings have created the concept of
super
intelligence sure but does it does it
mean does it
not it still could mean that that's a
projection from The Real World where
like we're just assigning words and
Concepts to a thing that
is fundamental to the real world that
there is something out there that is a
creative Force underlying the universe
um I think the universe there is a
creative force in the universe but I
don't think it's it's sentient I mean I
think the so I do not understand the
universe so who am I to say you know
um that that God doesn't exist I am an
atheist but I'm not an angry atheist
right I have lots of I have lots of
there are some people I know that are
angry atheists and say you know CR say
that religious people are stupid I don't
think that's the um I have faith in some
things cuz I don't I mean when I was a
kid I kept like you know like I need to
know what the charge of electron is like
I can't measure the charge on electron
that was you know I was just gave up and
had Faith okay you know resistors worked
so when it comes
the I want to know why the universe is
growing in the future and what humanity
is going to become and I've seen that
the the acquisition of
knowledge via the gener ation of novelty
to produce technology has uniformly made
hum lives better MH I would love to
continue that tradition
and you said that there's that creative
Force do do you think just to think on
that point do you think there's a
creative Force like is there like a
thing like a
driver that's like that's creating stuff
yeah I think that so I think that and
where what what is can you describe it
like Ma well I think selection I think
selection selection is the force
selection is the force in the universe
it creates
novelty so is selection somehow
fundamental like what what yeah I think
Persistence of objects that could Decay
into nothing through operations that
maintain that structure I mean think
about it if um it's amazing that things
exist at all that we're just not a big
commentarial mess yes so the fact and
they exist and they I thing that exist
persistent time yeah may I mean let's
think maybe the universe is
actually in the present the things
everything that can exist in the present
does
exist well that would mean it's
deterministic right no I think the
universities might so the universe
started super small the past was
deterministic there wasn't much going on
and it was able to mine mine mine mine
mine and so the process I mean is um
somehow
generating um universe is
basically I can't put I'm trying to put
this into did you just say there's no
free will though no I didn't say that if
can't exist I said there is Free Will I
think I think I I I'm saying that Free
Will occurs at the boundary between
the the future the past and the future
yeah I got you but everything that can
exist does exist everything that is so
everything that's possible to exist at
this so no I'm really put there's a lot
of loaded words there in there's a time
element loaded into that I I think that
the universe is able to do what it can
in the present right yeah and then I
think in the future there are other
things that could be possible we can
imagine lots of things but they don't
all happen sure so what that's what I
guess sneak in Free Will right there
yeah so I guess I'm saying is what what
exists is a com is a convolution of the
past with the present and the Free Will
going into the future well we can still
imagine stuff right we can imagine stuff
that never happen and it's amazing Force
because your imagin this is the the most
important thing that we don't understand
is our imaginations can actually change
the future in a tangible way which is
what the the initial conditions and
physics cannot predict like your IM
ination has a causal consequence in the
future isn't that weird to you
yeah how do
you it breaks breaks the laws of physics
as we know them right
now yeah so you think the imagination
has a causal effect in the future yeah
but it does exist in there in the head
and there must be a lot of power in
whatever is going on there could be a
lot of power whatever's going on in
there if we then go back to initial
conditions yeah and that it's simply not
possible that can happen but if we go
into if we go into a universe where we
accept that there is a finite ability to
represent numbers and you have rounding
well not rounding errors you have S the
S what happens the your ability to make
decisions imagine and do stuff is at
that interface between the certain and
the uncertain it's not as Yasha was
saying to me Randomness goes and you
just you know randomly do random stuff
it is that you are set free a little on
your trajectory Free Will is about being
able to explore on this narrow
trajectory um that allows you to build
you have a choice about what you build
or that choice is uh you interacting
with a future in the
present what do you is most beautiful
about this whole
thing the
universe the the the fact it seems to be
very undecided very open mhm and the
fact that
um every time I think I'm getting
towards an answer to a question there
are so many more questions that make the
the chase you know um do you hate that
it's going to be over at some point for
you no I I well for me I don't so I I I
I think if you think about it is it over
for Newton
now Newton has had causal consequences
in the future we discuss him all the
time his ideas but not the person the
person just had a lot of causal power
when he was alive but oh my God one of
the things I want to do is leave as many
Easter eggs in the future when I'm gone
to go oh that's cool would you be very
upset if somebody made a like a good L
large language model that's fine tuned
to Lee croner it would be quite boring
because I mean I mean I I'm no novelty
generation I would I mean if it's a
faithful representation of what I've
done in my life that's great that's
that's a interesting artifact but I
think the most most interesting thing
about no knowing each other as we don't
know what we're going to do next
sure sure I mean within some constraints
I've got you know you might I I can
predict some things about you you can
predict some things about me but we
can't predict everything everything and
it's because we can't predict everything
is why we're exciting to come back and
discuss and see it's so yeah I'm I'm I'm
I'm kind of H I'm happy that it'll be
interesting that some things I've done
can be captured but I'm pretty sure that
my
angle on mining novelty from the future
will not be
captured
yeah
yeah so that that's what life is it's
just uh some novelty generation and then
you're
done each one of us just generally a
little bit or have the capacity to at
least I think life is a selection
produces life and life affects Universe
in the universes with life in them are
materially physically fundamentally
different than universes without life
and that's super interesting and I I
have no beginnings of understanding I
think maybe this is like in a thousand
years there'll be a new discipline in
the humans will be yeah of course this
is how it all works right and um in
retrospect it will all be obvious I
think I think assembly theory is obvious
that's why a lot of people got angry
right they were like oh my God this is
such nonsense you know like oh you know
now actually it's not quite but the the
writing's really
bad well I can't wait to see where it
evolves uh Le and I I'm glad I get to
exist in this universe with you you're a
fascinating human this is always a
pleasure I hope to talk to you many more
many more times and I'm a huge fan of
just watching you create stuff in this
world and thank you for talking today
it's a pleasure as always Lex thanks for
having me
on
that